okay folks a lot of you have finished by
now if you're not done that's okay
um they won't take you that long i want
us all to go down to eight now
okay eight's actually really important
and it's it's one of the out of this
whole page actually it's probably the
biggest time saver
okay a is about odd and even functions
right which you can see it says if f is
odd
or if f is even along the end okay eight
and nine are both in the same kind of
category
now what do these mean how do we prove
these okay
now here's the situation they give you
let's take um
let's take even first okay so they're
saying
if you go from minus a to a of this
function right so you this is the area
you're after okay what is it equal to
if if
okay that's my question so remind me
again
what is the definition of evenness what
makes a function here
it is symmetrical about the y axis
so i can say for instance
i'm not sure there is a primary school
definition for even odd functions
um basically yeah so we've got this
symmetry happening
yeah now what does that mean for our
integral okay because this corresponds
to an area
if i go from minus a to a that means
that i'm getting this kind of result
this kind of area okay now just looking
at it you ought to expect that we should
be able to take advantage of the
symmetry
in this situation to reduce that
workload
okay uh what would you expect it to be
well you should be able to say if that's
minus a
that's a and that's zero okay if i want
to work out that whole area
now whole shaded thing i should just be
able to take one half of it like say
this half
and double it okay now you tell me apart
from the fact that
that's neat that we can why might i want
to do that
why might that be better off like
it's an integral or another interval
what makes this better and the answer is
like daniel said it's a zero okay zero
is more that's always the easiest thing
to evaluate
okay so it's going to just make your
numbers easier to work with when you get
to your definition
so how do i prove it how do i prove
that these two are equivalent
now graphically is okay but unless you
know
i mean it's not particularly rigorous my
my world
okay how am i going to prove it
algebraically that's going to be a
little more
concrete
ah good so if f is even
right i don't just have this kind of
geometric description
on this property of it algebraically the
definition of evenness is that
f of x and f of minus x are related
in what way they're equal to each other
they're identical okay that's what makes
the symmetry okay
f of a that value is equal to f of minus
a
okay how are we going to use it when we
do this
how's it gonna work okay well
uh i'm going to have my um my primitive
voice right
so in in much the same way we've been
doing all the other ones right
i've got my upper and lower bounds here
minus a it's an a
okay now what's this thing equal to
okay now stop for a second and think
with me
this isn't as obvious as it looks
what's going on now what do we i i
thought i could use this
but i don't even have lowercase f's in
sight anymore
what's happened it's an old function
oh no it doesn't have
don't you don't have to tell me but
hands up who feels they're confident if
if i did ask you
to stand up for tomorrow um if i
actually stand up and explain
how can i get you get from here to what
i said before this doubling
who reckons they could explain why can
anyone see it yet is anyone there
yeah you reckon i won't make you do it
kinda maybe
sauna
okay now we need to do a bit of a detour
first and we need to do a bit of a
detour
because what i've got here is not my
function that i started with right i've
got the primitive okay so i've got to be
able to
connect these two somehow okay so what's
the connection between the primitive
and the function i started with right
well it's
differentiation yeah so i know that this
is even
and i've got to say something about this
okay so
what am i going to do yeah
sorry this one or this one this one yeah
that's that's true if f but
so
is
which is on to something in case you
hadn't noticed okay so let's let's give
an example
okay what he's talking about uh let's
take a function that we know to be
um that we know to be even okay let's
take x squared
now if i were to integrate that okay
work out what its cumulative was
so i should call that f if i get capital
f
okay if i enter differentiate what's the
answer
plus okay now
richard is right is this odd or is it
even
or is it neither it is potentially
necessarily the answer is we don't know
yet what does it depend on
sorry start again i'll tell you right
now it can't possibly be
even why not because
that cube there right if you stick
negatives in there they can come back
right so that's a problem for us it
can't be even
it might be odd what's going to decide
whether it's odd or not
it determines it depends on the value of
the constant okay so
if i want it to be an odd function what
do i need the constant
zero it has to be zero
okay now stay with me stay with me okay
i can actually know that it is zero
house how can i know that it's zero
because the gradient at the point in the
middle of and what's this function is
zero
on an even function is zero what kind of
integrals we look at again no that's not
y
what kind of integrals are we looking at
there are two kinds intervals we're
looking at definite integrals right
so when i'm working with definite
integrals i can ignore the constant
this makes sense only with definite
integrals this is why it's properties of
definitely because they're not just
integrals in general okay um because it
has to be attached to an actual area if
it's not i'm in trouble
okay so now coming back here
right i can actually say
as i should put it here i suppose
as f is even
okay i can say if
prime is odd okay not f
prime including the constant like that
whole family the indefinite integral
but the definite integral will be odd i
can know because
eventually my clusters will cancel out
okay this makes sense
all right so therefore if f prime the
primitive is odd what statement can i
make here
i can turn that into the other thing
okay what's your that
f x is equal to minus f of minus x i
should put capitals because that's what
we're talking about
okay so this is the algebraic definition
of an odd function or you could slap the
minus sign on that side
if you're like it wouldn't matter okay
uh the way that she said it actually
first was
the best way because that right hand
side there that's what i have
isn't it except with an a yes so here
as f prime as the primitive is i i can
say that's
equal to this
okay and this is what we wanted
yes now this is important
because i can now move back to this kind
of thing
right lowercase
is finding area right if i if i'm doing
a definite integral
i am finding area so that is what it
looks like
okay now i i think probably having
demonstrated with evenness right and
i've noted this thing
okay i think you could probably do the
proof for if it were an
odd function if i change this
okay if it's odd something like say x
cubed
if i'm going from minus a to a
because they're going to be exactly
equal to each other but on opposite
sides of the axis
right that's why the definite integral
will be equal to as the sheet says
zero okay and i think you can probably
prove that for yourself
right so leave a bit of space do that
underneath and um
actually i'll let you do that now why
don't you do that now rehearse the same
proof but do it for
um